The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GARY GENSLER: So let's
turn to this world
of initial coin offerings.
And so we're going to chat
about it today and next Tuesday.
Next Tuesday, we'll come back
to the regulatory side of this.
And in fact, there were
some new things out
of the Securities and
Exchange Commission
even last week on
initial coin offerings.
But we're going to spend a
little time on ICOs today.
And so of course, we've
talked about Bakkt already.
And we'll talk about
their characteristics.
What is an initial
coin offering?
What is this new
form of crowdfunding?
How to evaluate initial coin
offerings-- and some of this
will be familiar,
because it's how
to really evaluate any
blockchain technology
project in some regard.
And then I'm going to
share some statistics,
and then hopefully wish you
all a Happy Thanksgiving
and call it a day.
So the study
question was, what is
this new form of crowdfunding?
Does anybody want to tell me?
What is an ICO in
the easiest way?
You're going home for
Thanksgiving and somebody says,
what have you been studying?
And you say ICOs.
What is an ICO?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's a startup
that sells its own crypto
token to raise money.
GARY GENSLER: So it's a--
AUDIENCE: Sells its own
crypto token to raise money.
GARY GENSLER: So it's a way
to raise money with a crypto
token, pretty simple.
AUDIENCE: And in
addition to that,
it gives people an expectation
that the token's value
will go up in the future.
GARY GENSLER: Did anybody read
the optional reading for today
about the dude that actually
came up with this idea?
Do you remember his name?
|
AUDIENCE: JR.
GARY GENSLER: JR,
Willett, is it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
I mean, I don't know if
anybody watched the video,
but this individual
in 2010 came up
with an idea of saying
Bitcoin is out there.
I mean, Bitcoin was
selling for like $0.06,
$0.10 a Bitcoin or something.
He said, if you could put
something on top of Bitcoin--
I don't even know if you
use the term smart contract.
But he did say, if you
could put an application
on top of Bitcoin-- it
was before Vitalik Buterin
came along with Ethereum.
He said, you could
raise a lot of money.
And he went to conference
after conference
and tried to convince people.
And there's even
this one feedback
where somebody said to
him in an email exchange,
you're probably
breaking the law.
This can't be legal.
But he couldn't get
anybody to adopt this idea.
And he's not wealthy now either.
He missed the whole ICO
way, but he was basically
the inventor of this
initial coin offering,
saying that the
technology of Bitcoin,
even the scripting
language, was enough
that you could maybe raise
money on top of Bitcoin
with an application layer.
And we'll sort through.
Now, I'm going to see if I
can do a little video for you.
This shouldn't be
too hard for me.
So this is a two minute
video of all the ICOs
that have ever happened.
And Elementus, I've
shown you this picture,
but you know there wasn't much.
Where we are we?
Are we in 2015 now?
Nothing.
So you see the
first ICO that they
mark in there is Ethereum
itself raised $18 million.
I apologize.
It's only going to
take two minutes,
but you're going to see
the whole history of ICOs.
And then there's nothing.
It's really-- so you
can see no country,
no official sector is really
focused on this in 2016.
But then there's going
to be a big offering
in the middle of 2016.
Anybody know who that is?
Dow.
$168 million, and it fails.
It spectacularly fails.
$50 million of it is stolen
and it leads to the Ethereum
fork and things like that.
But still not a lot, and
then, by the summer of '17,
Katy bar the door.
Tasos and quarter billion
dollars, Filecoin,
a quarter billion dollars.
And then oh, I pulled the
one that finished in 2017.
I'm sorry.
So there's the final chart
that goes all the way
through August.
Now, some say that
it's not $28 billion.
Some say it's $23
billion, because there's
no really good figures.
But EOS raises $4.2 billion and
Telegram raises $1.7 billion,
huge amounts of money.
And this is in a period--
almost all of this was raised
and in about 12 months,
from June of '17 to June of '18.
Call it $25 billion
in that 12 months.
And now, it's trickling off.
Now, it's less than
$0.5 billion month.
But that $25
billion in 12 months
compares to venture capital--
and Simone, you might help me.
But venture capital worldwide
is about $150 billion
a year in a 12 month period.
I think the figures range
from $125 to $170 billion.
So just to give you a
sense, in this 12 month
period, it's, give or take,
20% of the size of all venture
funds, 20% to 30% roughly
of all venture funds.
And again, it's tailing
off, but it's significant.
If you can come up with
an idea in these 12 months
and raise the money,
JR Willett's idea,
this was the moment.
So what are initial
coin offerings?
What's the more detailed
characteristics?
Well, number one,
they're proceeds
that help build a network.
That's what Vitalik
Buterin actually did back
in 2013 is when he published,
in 2014 is when he went live.
But he was raising $18 million,
hired a law firm, big, big law
firm in--
I can't remember if it was
Perkins or Skadden Arps,
but a big US law firm, partnered
up with a Canadian, Joe
Lubin, who saw this
potential in a 19
or 20-year-old kid who
had great writing skills.
He knew a lot about Bitcoin.
He had been writing about
it for a number of years,
but he also had a great idea.
He moved off to Switzerland for
regulatory and other reasons
set up a foundation for
tax and other reasons,
and did it in a very
professional way.
But you can look at
their sources and uses.
You can go back to
the original offering
and say they were willing
to say what they were going
to use the $18 million for--
law fees and counting fees
and the usual things you
do when you start something.
So it's proceeds to
help build up a network.
But just like that moment,
it was before the network
could be used.
So that was pre-functional.
We're going to show
statistics later,
but anybody want to take
a gander in the last three
months.
So this isn't back 2014.
I'm talking about
third quarter of 2018.
What percentage
of token offerings
were offered before the
network is functional, fully
functional?
Alin?
AUDIENCE: 99%.
GARY GENSLER: Anybody
else want to take a--
argue with Alin?
Just because he is a
computer scientist?
Tom?
AUDIENCE: I was
going to say 95%.
GARY GENSLER: All right, 95%.
All right, so
we've got a market.
So 95%, 99%.
Does anybody want to say that
more than 5% were functional?
No?
All right, I'll give
you the number later.
It's in between the two of you.
So it's raising money before
something is functional.
It's like raising the
money for a Broadway play
before you've got the
actors and the script.
Or it's even worse than that.
You don't even have the idea.
But usually, you have an idea.
Usually-- what
percentage of ICOs
are marketed on just an idea?
Anybody?
I have that
statistic later, too.
Rahim, you have a view?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I would
think maybe of these
with an idea, maybe 60% to 70%.
GARY GENSLER: 60% to 70%.
Sean?
AUDIENCE: I would say 90%.
GARY GENSLER: 90%.
All right, no, it's in
between the two of you.
Rahim is a little closer.
It's about 75%, just an
idea, or at least as defined
by a certain tracking center.
So it's usually you have
an idea, you market it,
you raise some
money, or at least
during these boom periods
in the last 15 months.
The development, while open
source, is largely centralized.
But in fact, in
the last quarter,
the last three
months, well over half
isn't even open source
technology any longer,
partly because it's so
based on just an idea
that people aren't publishing
their source code until later.
They will eventually
publish some source code.
But at the moment of the
initial coin offering,
a majority don't even have open
source software at that moment,
even though they say later
they'll publish this software.
But even if it's open source,
it's highly centralized.
Please.
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
how open source is related
to [INAUDIBLE] if I say I'm
going to sell something,
these are the coins you
should use to pay me back.
Where is open source connected?
GARY GENSLER: So
there's a movement
in technology and
software development--
certainly, it was
started in the 1990s,
but it may have been earlier.
But now, it's very
prevalent-- where
you publish your software
and everybody can see it.
So it's transparency
in software.
That's called the
open source movement.
In the blockchain technology,
when Satoshi Nakamoto first
published the Bitcoin
software in January of 2009,
it was open source.
It meant everybody could
see the computer code.
And you could even--
it's actually
published under an MIT
license, which meant you didn't
have to pay any fee to use it.
Zero fee, you can copy it,
you can use the Bitcoin core
software.
That's the definition.
That's the best
definition of open source,
because it's with
an MIT license.
But it's truly open.
That's what I'm
referencing here.
And the relevance is
that, though there
is a big open source
movement in a lot of fields
and in blockchain and
certainly in Bitcoin
and the Ethereum
network is open source,
many, many developments
and initial coin offerings
don't publish their
code until months later.
They raise the money, they're
still developing their code.
Are you with me?
So Brotish?
AUDIENCE: So why do
investors put in their money
even before the
code is published?
GARY GENSLER: So
why do investors
put their money in before
the code is published?
Why do investors put
money into any investment?
Sabrina?
AUDIENCE: FOMO.
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
GARY GENSLER: What's FOMO?
Fear of missing out.
All right.
Oh by the way,
Sabrina and Thalita,
I announced that anybody
that was here today
got double credit for
participating right
before Thanksgiving.
So I just want to let you know.
I live by that.
So fear of missing out.
Why else do people
invest in any investment,
even if you're just
investing in Apple stock?
AUDIENCE: To get returns.
GARY GENSLER: To get
returns, to get a profit,
to take risk and a return.
Brotish?
AUDIENCE: I think in
one of the readings
they mentioned that one strategy
of putting money in an ICO
is going to the board
and understanding.
So I thought that that
was a prerequisite
for the investment.
I also happened to
attend one seminar here
where there was a
company called BlockTEST,
which is funded by a--
GARY GENSLER: What's it called?
Block--
AUDIENCE: BlockTEST.
It's MIT alumni.
So they evaluate these
codes and run some solutions
to verify whether
they're doing what
they're supposed to be doing.
So I thought that it
was a prerequisite
for the investment.
So that's where my
question came from.
GARY GENSLER: So you assume that
you could always read the code
to make the investment.
In the fall of 2017 and
into the spring of 2018,
I would suggest that
wasn't always the case.
And in fact, it usually
was not the case.
I think if these
things are to persist,
my prediction is you'll
see more and more rigor
in this marketplace.
Oh, I skipped promoters.
The people starting it keep some
of the coins for themselves.
This is not that different
from any venture capital round.
When you're raising
money and you're
selling equity or selling a
preferred stock in something--
you'll know this, any
of your taking ventures
course or if you worked in it--
you're going to keep equity
for yourself as well.
So this is just how much
do you keep for yourself,
how much do you
sell to the public,
but just translated to a
new form of capital raising.
Instead of it being
applied to your equity,
you're applying it to this
new form of fund raising.
They're fungible
and transferable,
meaning you can sell them.
Sometimes, you can't sell
them for a number of months.
Technically speaking,
sometimes you
can't sell him until the
platform is functioning.
But often, you can
still sell them
by private agreement,
private arrangements.
Ethereum-- let me just mention
something about Ethereum.
When Ethereum was first sold,
for 12 months, the only record
you had that you were
purchasing Ethereum was
the email return back from
either Vitalik or others who
said, yes, you've purchased it.
It wasn't even that you had
a private key for 12 months.
You had an email confirmation.
But you could, based on
that email confirmation,
sell the right to what later
you would be issued, a coin.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
along those lines,
I've seen a number of ICOs
use SAFTs, simple agreement
for future tokens.
And I guess I'm wondering
what the trade-offs are
versus directly issuing the
tokens at time of the ICO.
And then more specifically, that
just feels like you're not even
getting the token,
you're not even
getting the rights to the token
until the network launches.
That seems like a second
order, really far removal
from even close to any form
of a utility on a network.
GARY GENSLER: Is this
an answer to the SAFT?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So isn't it because
under the US--
I mean, right now,
the coins aren't
considered as a security.
And if you are
doing ICOs, then you
can only sell it to accredited
investors [INAUDIBLE]
if you are based
in the US, and you
can do some things other
than that outside the US.
And so I think SAP is
trying to see if coins can--
at some point, they can
be considered as not
as securities.
So I think the purpose
of SAP is to, I guess,
expand the basically
investor base so
that more people can purchase.
GARY GENSLER: So
it's Jihee right?
So Jihee's answer delved
into the regulatory,
but I'm going to take it up
a level from the regulatory.
What you said was
accurate, but there's a--
it's selling something
for future delivery,
because the token
currently is not usable.
Just in the last quarter, I'm
talking about the last quarter
of 2018, three
quarters of the ICOs
that were started or launched
were just on an idea.
So they hadn't yet
written the code.
A token wouldn't even be usable.
So you have some
economic basis to say,
I'm trying to sell you something
that will be a future delivery.
When Vitalik Buterin even did
Ethereum, you got an email.
It was not called a simple
agreement for future token.
Is that what SAFT is?
But it was a simple
email for a future token.
I mean, it was, in essence,
an economic arrangement
where you exchanged
Bitcoin for an email.
And that email, some
12 months later,
you would get a private key
when the genesis block happened.
And most of these
still had to deal
with that economic arrangement.
Then a law firm
here in Boston took
an arrangement that was
handled in securities offerings
and they created something,
and they put out, in essence,
a legal white
paper, if you wish,
called a Simple Agreement
for Future Tokens, SAFT,
to try to address,
they thought--
they thought-- I think they
were wrong, by the way.
But they thought
they were addressing
a bunch of regulatory issues
that somehow this SAFT, this
would be maybe have to register
under the securities laws
in the US.
But when you finally
got the token,
maybe later it would not have
to be a registered security.
And they were trying to do
a two-tiered arrangement.
But even before you got to this
Boston law firm that did this,
you still had the
economic reality
that you were trying
to raise money
today to get a token later.
And then the lawyers
got involved to try to--
I would say they
were trying to get
between the wallpaper and
the wall of regulation
and say, we'll register
the first thing,
we'll give it a fancy name.
We'll call it a SAFT.
We won't register the second
thing when you finally
get the token 12 months later.
I think they'll probably
end up mistaken on that.
But I think that
was the background.
Let me hit a couple
other points.
Scarcity is usually,
but not always, fostered
through some monetary policy.
If we go back to Nakamoto
consensus and Bitcoin,
what's the monetary
policy there?
Anybody remember that monetary?
I call it monetary
policy, but it's
the control of the supply
of the money supply.
So what's the money supply
algorithm in Bitcoin?
Eilon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Half?
Half of what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
reward for the blocks.
GARY GENSLER: So
there's a reward.
The Bitcoin monetary
policy is a reward of--
anybody remember
the reward today?
AUDIENCE: 12.5 coins.
GARY GENSLER: 12
and 1/2 coins today.
It started at 50 coins
every how many minutes?
10 minutes on average.
But every 200,000
blocks, it halves.
So somewhere out in
the 22nd century,
it will cap at 21 million coins.
But way before that,
the monetary policy,
it's slowing and slowing
and slowing the growth rate.
So embedded in the algorithm of
Bitcoin is a monetary policy.
Is it immutable?
How many people would say
that's hard coded and immutable?
Not a hand.
How many people would say
it's actually not immutable?
So what can change it?
Alan, you didn't raise
your hand either way.
AUDIENCE: It depends how
you define immutable.
GARY GENSLER: Yes,
I'm listening.
AUDIENCE: If you change
the monetary policy,
you're going to have a fork.
You're going to have
the old folks sticking
with the old policy
and the new folks
sticking with the new policy.
And now, what has changed?
Some people argue nothing
has changed, while others
argue something has seen.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So Alin's pointing out not
everybody will go along
with the new monetary policy.
But I would note on
Ethereum, they've
changed their monetary
policy two or three times.
And they haven't had
to use a hard fork.
So they've changed
their block reward.
And in changing a block reward,
by lowering the block rewards,
by consensus, they
effectively are
changing their monetary policy,
because they're changing,
in essence, their
inflation rate.
But most initial coin
offerings have some algorithm,
some built in, what we'll
call, money supply policy
or monetary policy,
but not all of them do.
Some, if you read
them closely, they
can issue as much as they
want whenever they want
and so forth.
But I would say the majority
have a monetary policy.
If this space, if this
world really took off a,
lot of monetary policy
economists would study it.
But there's not a
lot of deep research
yet on what works,
what doesn't work.
It's a playground
or a sandbox if it
were to ever take
off as to exploring
hard monetary policies.
Sean?
AUDIENCE: So just based
on those six criteria,
maybe apart from the last one.
It looks to me like--
GARY GENSLER: You want
to get rid of that one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It looks to me
like a Kickstarter.
GARY GENSLER: Like a what?
AUDIENCE: A Kickstarter.
GARY GENSLER: A Kickstarter.
So this looks like
Kickstarter to you?
But does Kickstarter
give you something else?
Anything?
AUDIENCE: It depends on how
you structure the terms.
Basically, most of the items
that are posted on Kickstarter,
they use the funding
to build their product.
It's before it's
actually functional.
And it's also open source.
It's pretty much the same.
GARY GENSLER: Shimon?
AUDIENCE: There's a
very big difference,
which is that Kickstarter,
you fix the price
and you let the market
determine the quantity, right?
And arguably, you
fix the quantity
and you let the market
determine the price.
That's a big difference
between those two,
and the fact that there's
a secondary market, right?
You can also sell your items,
lieke the super early bird
items in a secondary market.
Sure, you could.
And again, this is nothing--
yes, you can.
I mean, I would argue that
it's a lot harder, right?
But it also is the case that,
if I'm selling a new widget,
I'm not going to sell the
early birds for $30, right?
That's the price, right?
And here, you're letting--
the auction is for the
price not for the coin.
GARY GENSLER: So there are
similarities to Kickstarter.
There's similarities to other
crowd funding mechanisms,
but there's also some real
distinctions in terms of--
one, of course, this
is all digital assets.
And Kickstarter often there
is a service or a good,
a physical good, or a
service you're getting.
But also, what Shimon does?
Hugo?
AUDIENCE: Just to push
back on that last point,
often the ICOs are
priced in theory.
And then only on the secondary
markets do the prices change.
Isn't that the case?
If you want to spit
in an ICO, they'll
be like, oh, here's 1,000 points
for 0.1 F. And that, I guess,
varies based on price
fluctuations in US dollars,
if you're still
taking US dollars.
But since you're using
Ether to pay for the ICO--
GARY GENSLER: Hugo's
saying it's not really
that price is variable until it
gets to the secondary market.
But I would contend that one
big difference between most
of what's done on
Kickstarter, not everything
but most, and here
is here the investors
really are looking
and anticipating
profits and returns.
And when I think
of most people that
are going into
Kickstarter, they're
getting one product, one unit
of something as a reward.
And they're not looking
for a significant profit
or appreciation.
They could-- maybe a
modest, but not a--
AUDIENCE: The secondary market--
the super early birds in
the secondary market--
GARY GENSLER: Super
early birds, yeah.
So there is monetary
policy and this last point,
that purchases really
are anticipating profits
through appreciation.
So that's what I think of.
Now, how to you evaluate ICOs?
You're not going to be
surprised by my first one.
It's what we've talked a
lot about in this class.
Assess the viability
of the token use case.
Like, does it make any sense?
Does it make any sense?
Do you need to use
an append only log
with a consensus among
a bunch of parties
that can write to a ledger?
So append only
logs and consensus,
throw a bunch of
cryptography in there, too.
And do you need a native token?
Those basic
fundamental economics
that we've talked about
a lot this semester,
hopefully, will save
you off from investing
in really bad ICOs.
But beyond that, which I think
is over 50% of what you should
do, read the white paper.
I tell you, if anybody could
read the Telegraph white paper
that they raised $1.7
billion and please tell me--
feel free to tell
me what they are
going to use that
money for, because I've
read it a number of times
and I wouldn't invest in it,
because it felt like they
could raise the money
and do almost anything
they want with it.
I mean, they're an
incredible company.
They've got hundreds
of millions of users.
And they have incredible
resources to draw upon,
but I'm still not sure
what they're using--
what I will ultimately be
able to use the coin for,
what service I
can get from that,
and what they're
using the money for.
So I would say, read
the white paper.
And if there's
source code, which
is less than half the
time there's source code,
have somebody you
trust read the source
code if you can't read it.
Who's the team?
Just like any venture
capital investor,
you want to know who's the team.
What's their history?
What's their experience
and so forth?
But I start with the
economics and the white paper
before I get to the
team and the website.
Is there venture
capital involvement,
and who and which ones?
Now, VCs often will
take part of the--
at this stage will take
part of the equity and also
part of the coin round.
So they're doing
hybrid investments.
It's very rare, now
in November of 2018,
that a venture
capitalist will only
take a part of the token round.
In late '17, there were still
some they were just getting
on this parade and
taking parts of the pre--
basically, the
pre-round of the tokens.
But now, they want part of
the actual equity and tokens.
Erik, were you asking?
AUDIENCE: No, it's just
that's exactly what we
got from a VC that mentioned
that they go with a free ICO
round of investment
first as a means
to assess the capability
of the full body offering,
and then go through
the ICO again.
GARY GENSLER: But
their first investment
is either preferred or an
equity-like instrument.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
And I feel like it changes
completely the time
from the investment for a
venture capitalist, which
normally would for
five to 10 years.
And here, it's like
you're going to hide
for the next few months, and
then just resell the coins
right after.
What is the time frame?
GARY GENSLER: So
Alexis's observation
is this might shorten the time
frame for venture capitalists.
I would say yes during
this 2017-2018 period.
I don't know if
that will persist.
But yes, I think that, for
venture capitalists saying,
well, I can be taken up
by selling the company,
I can be taken out
of my investor term--
how am I going to sell my
investment, my take out?
I can take the company public,
I can sell the company, or maybe
I can ICO, and if
you can do it sooner.
And what happened a lot in
the fall of '17 and into '18
is many venture
capitalists changed
their standard contracts and
their standard documentation
when they were
investing in start ups
to say also that they could
participate in the ICO round
and that they could participate
in the early rounds.
But if you're assessing
an ICO and you're
thinking about
investing in it, you
want to know what venture
capitalists are backing it.
And then a big thing
that folks look at--
I put it fifth on the
list, as you can see--
is what's the community.
How many Redis
post, Medium posts?
How many people are following
Bitcoin talk, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera?
There's eight or 10 of
these talk channels.
And I don't know
the ratios anymore,
but it used to be
if you could get
to like 7,000 to 10,000
folks following you on Reddit
and Medium and
everything, you knew
you could raise
a successful ICO.
Like in the heyday, if
you could get your numbers
to a certain
following, then that
was enough momentum to raise
your $15 to $30 million.
I think that's probably
a little less so now.
Tom?
AUDIENCE: I mean, this is just
the definition of the greater
fool theory, right?
If enough people believe
that your token is valuable,
then it's valuable.
So I get that it's the fifth
thing on the list for a reason.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
But if you're a
momentum investor
and you're just saying--
or if it's FOMO
investing as Sabrina
said, to see how big
the community is.
And is there an interest in it?
Does this have a following?
I said I'm neither a
maximalist nor a minimalist.
I'm just not--
I'm not trying to--
but this is real economics.
If you had 100,000 people
following in a community,
probably more likely
it's a successful ICO
in terms of raising money.
It doesn't mean it's going to be
successful as a token later on.
Here?
AUDIENCE: You don't actually
use it as a specific criterion,
but you can use it maybe as
a filter, the first filter.
If you have that
the person who's
publishing the white
paper has not been posted,
he's never been
there, then it raises
a little bit of suspicion.
And then you have to
go on and do some more
research on the paper, on the
idea, on the guy, whatever.
GARY GENSLER: It is a way
to see whether there's
other people even tuning
in and showing interest.
And it could be the
greater fool theory
just because if Tim
Draper, Mike Novogratz
is invested, who are both
very savvy investors and very
successful investors, you
might say, do I want to be in?
Or is that my time to
say it's not to be in,
because they've already
gotten the best of it.
Either way, I mean, they're
still good investors.
What's their monetary policy?
Again, how's it
going to affect--
can they-- is it one
of the majority that
has a fixed monetary policy?
Or is it one of
the minority that
has no monetary policy at all?
How did they
distribute the tokens?
And I mean in two ways.
Basically, some will actually
disclose a cap table,
a capitalization table of
the tokens, the same way
you can think of a
capitalization table of equity,
but who owns the tokens
pre-sale and post-sale.
So that's what I mean
by token distribution.
Are they keeping 10% for the
founder or 80% for the founder?
It might change your
view on all of it.
But also token distribution
is how are they selling it
during what's usually a 30 to
60 day period or 15 to 60 day
period.
The longest that I am
aware of is 350 days.
EOS sold over 350 days.
Every day was a form
of a Dutch auction.
It was a remarkable way
that they sold 4.2 billion.
I doubt that anybody who
did EOS at the beginning
thought they were going
to raise over $1 billion.
In fact, maybe nobody thought
they'd raise over $100 million,
because they started
in the summer of '17.
But they did a
distribution over 350 days.
Most, though, are done
over 15 to 60 days or so.
Please.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned [INAUDIBLE]
how are ICOs accounted for?
Do they go as equity
on their revenue?
Where do they fall?
GARY GENSLER: So
terrific question.
How are ICO proceeds
accounted for?
Who's our accountant?
Aviva?
AUDIENCE: No idea.
GARY GENSLER: All right,
no idea from Aviva.
I want to try to
answer it, but anybody?
AUDIENCE: I think that's
another important feature.
It's the token economics, how
you use potential incentive,
[INAUDIBLE] and for the
profit of the project,
the project would
repurchase their tokens
in a way similar to a dividend.
GARY GENSLER: But
how do you book it?
What's the debit and
what's the credit?
AUDIENCE: Marketable
securities and cash.
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: I hope this works.
You know of the
T account, right?
We've got the T account.
Over here's cash, right?
Because you receive cash
when you sell something.
What's the credit item?
AUDIENCE: Question mark.
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Retained earnings.
GARY GENSLER: You think
it's retained earnings?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GARY GENSLER: You think
it's just retained earnings?
AUDIENCE: They're
selling nothing.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So the question
is, is it earnings?
Is it a revenue item
when you sell it?
Or some people book it
as deferred revenue.
So there's two ways
you can book it.
You could also book
it as a liability,
but it's either deferred
revenue or current revenue.
All right, what could
motivate you to book
it as a deferred revenue
instead of current revenue?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Taxes, probably.
GARY GENSLER: Taxes.
So some book it as
deferred revenues,
because they don't
want to book taxes.
And God knows whether
that's really the right way
to book it.
And others book it right as
a revenue item right now.
But I don't know of anybody,
whether they're booking it
as deferred revenues or
current revenues, that
wants to book it to trigger
that it's a security.
So most law firms that I
understand, they're not they're
not accountants, but they
don't want their clients
to book it in a way that will
make it look more like equity.
So it's either deferred
revenue or current revenue.
Some, I've heard, have
called it a liability,
but I think that's the minority.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if it takes too much time
to go through a use case to
make these examples tangible.
If I'm promising
to deliver a good,
then the company is getting
back the tokens, right?
How do you put it back
out again in the market?
GARY GENSLER: So the question
is what is the use case.
So some use cases,
the token is issued
and it's really
for the community.
And some tokens come
back to the company.
So a file storage,
Filecoin, for instance,
they raised $250-some
million, the equivalent of.
And in that case,
I think the token
would be used
within the community
rather than back to the company.
So even like
Ethereum, when you use
Ethereum as a form of
buying computing power,
it doesn't go back to
the Ethereum Foundation.
So the most dominant--
and that's why it really should
be booked as current revenue,
because it's not even that the
software provider is providing
a service later.
The most dominant use
case is, like in Ethereum,
that you're using the Eth for
other people in the network.
It's a monetary unit
that's not coming back.
There are some
where it comes back,
and then it's basically returned
to the corporate treasury.
So it's two different models.
Have I lost you or
are you with me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: All right.
One way is that it gets
returned to the company.
That's the more narrow case.
Usually, it's you're selling
a token that will be used.
And I'll give it to
Eilon, because Eilon
gives me file storage.
Eilon will give it
to Tom, because Tom
gives Eilon file storage.
In Ethereum, it literally
keeps going around
and it doesn't get returned to--
it never gets burned and
never gets extinguished
and handed back to the company.
AUDIENCE: And the pricing
strategy on that first issuance
depends then on the value
of, if it's storage,
on the value of storing--
GARY GENSLER: Well, in theory--
it's theory.
I think that a lot of this has
been on speculation and FOMO
and things like that and a
bubble, a 15 month or 18 month
bubble.
But on theory,
yes, it should be--
to be in equilibrium,
it should be
a discount to the
future value of storage,
because today you're
buying a token that you
might be able to use tomorrow.
But because there's a
probability weighting
that you won't be able to
use it if they don't complete
the software, if they
don't complete the rollout,
it should sell at
a-- in equilibrium,
it should sell at a discount
to its eventual utility value.
That would be where it
would be in equilibrium.
Shimon?
AUDIENCE: So this is a question.
Even in the bad
use case, they're
not pre-determining
what one unit of coin
is good for, right?
GARY GENSLER: Usually not.
Some white papers
do, but usually not.
AUDIENCE: Because
it's not just--
if they told you,
OK, one unit will
buy you one terabyte of
storage, now, of course,
the value of a
terabyte of storage
would depend on the electricity,
cost of electricity,
and hardware, and all
that stuff in the future--
I don't know-- and the
supply, and blah, blah, blah.
[INAUDIBLE] It's very hard to
pin down the fundamental value
of that coin outside of
how it's going to scale
and how the community will
be and all that stuff,
because there's no
clear allocation
between the coin and the
service that you would get.
Does that make sense?
GARY GENSLER: Let me see.
You're asking absolutely
the right question.
It's one that I've been
kicking around a little bit
with a couple other faculty
members in the finance group
here, with Antoinette and Leonid
who have done a lot of research
in this area.
And we're all like,
we're not sure exactly.
And these are some
of the most world
class talented finance faculty.
Like, how do you really get
to the value of a token, one,
when there's so little
written in these white papers
about this specificity?
And I gave one reading, which
was Christian's reading,
and I apologize, because
it has a lot of formulas
and everything.
But he grapples with this.
Where is it in equilibrium?
What's the equilibrium price?
And the equilibrium
price should be
some discount to
that future value
of the service or the good.
And if there is more uncertainty
of what that service or good,
it almost has to be
a greater discount.
And yet, it appears that the
market has been pricing it
at a way premium.
So I think, if you
didn't take anything
from Christian's paper,
that's what I was trying
to-- that the market
has been at a premium,
even though it probably
should be discounted.
And that's why issuers--
that's why entrepreneurs have
tapped into it, because it's
a form of cheap financing.
It's been a remarkable
area of cheap financing.
Please.
AUDIENCE: So as we look
forward to Filecoin [INAUDIBLE]
so if we look at that and
we flash forward to when
it's actually functional
and whatever--
GARY GENSLER: And
it's no longer SAFT.
AUDIENCE: When it
actually ever comes out,
so is the idea that
Filecoin at that point
would transition to
realized revenue?
And then if I pay
Don, three Filecoins
or whatever the unit is for
storage, that he books that
as income and is taxed on that?
Has there been any
thought as to how--
GARY GENSLER: If Don
is selling files,
yes, he would have to book
income, as I understand it.
And you're transferring a coin,
just like you're transferring
a euro or a yen or a dollar.
And at the time, the IRS
has spoken to this five,
six years ago.
It's marked to
market value the day
that you, in essence,
deliver the service
and receive the coin.
I mean, I'm not
entirely sure what
happens if you get
the coin a day later,
but it's basically
the market value
at an exchange rate that day
back to Fiat, always translated
back to the Fiat currency,
in this case the US dollar.
AUDIENCE: So if you
extend that example,
where does Filecoin gain
revenue on the transaction
between Andrew and Don?
Are they charging
a transaction fee?
GARY GENSLER: I don't know.
I'll try to figure that
out by next Tuesday,
because we get ICOs twice.
I'll dig in and try to answer,
and if anybody else knows.
But the revenue models vary
with thousands of these.
Whether, in essence,
Filecoin's entire revenue model
was the ICO?
No?
The second big piece
of the revenue model
is retaining some ownership.
So let's look at
Ripple, the company.
Ripple, the company, though they
did their genesis block back
in 2013, they basically
distributed 20% of their tokens
and kept 80%.
And subsequently, they
have been slowly selling
and they're now down to 61%.
But their revenue model
on XRP is, in essence,
selling the XRP.
They only came up with
a real use case of XRP
in 2018 in a prototype
called XRapid.
They had XCurrent, which was
a messaging system prior that
didn't need to use XRP at all.
So for four years,
you had no use of XRP,
as I understand it zero use.
Today, it's the second
highest valued cryptocurrency.
It's past Ethereum with
the fall-off of the value
of Ethereum and Bitcoin.
And at $18 billion, I couldn't
tell you what it's worth.
I can tell you that's what
coinmarket.com or .cap says
they're worth.
But their revenue model is
selling XRP in that case.
And so many of them,
their revenue models
are the initial ICO, keep a
bucket, whether you keep 10%,
or in that case it was 80%, and
then try to monetize and sell
it over time.
And even in Ethereum, which
was, in essence, an ICO,
they kept about 9% in
the Ethereum Foundation.
They're down to 1% ownership
in the Ethereum Foundation.
So they don't receive--
and when Ethereum
moves around the network, the
Ethereum Foundation and Vitalik
Buterin don't
receive any of that.
But I'd have to look at Filecoin
to see whether, in essence,
they burn any.
In essence, does any of
it go back to the issuer?
I don't think so,
but I'll check.
Take this, and then we'll move
on to a couple statistics.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
who is regulating the ICO.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So who regulates
the ICOs we're going
to talk a lot about on Tuesday
after Thanksgiving, when we
can thank and eat some turkey.
So can we hold that for Tuesday?
But it really depends
on the jurisdiction.
Here in the US, it would be
the Securities and Exchange
Commission, because
most of these
are really non-compliant
securities offerings.
And last Friday, the
SEC put out a release.
I mean, they've put out
many, many releases.
But last Friday's,
maybe we'll put that up.
Sabrina and Thalita
if you remind me,
I'll shoot you a link and
we'll put it into Canvas.
But it's only two
or three pages.
But for the first
time, they really
talked about illegal
securities offerings.
So they used the word illegal.
And they're starting
to get to the place
where they're shutting some
of these down that were not
necessarily scammy
or fraudy, but just
saying you didn't register.
But generally speaking, it
would be securities regulators,
if it's regulated.
In some jurisdictions, it's not.
So this is the most
important thing.
Can you assess the
viability of token use case?
You remember my little slides.
But again, it's the
strategic questions.
And these are the same questions
I'm asking you to think about
in your final papers.
Basically, what's the
value creation proposition
or pain points?
What are competitors doing?
How are competitors
facing off in this?
And if you're
looking at any ICO,
just think about the
competitive landscape.
Some of them are quite populated
with a lot of competition.
File storage, Filecoin
is not the only one,
so you look at the others
and see how they're
addressing the same issues.
And really, why is a
blockchain technology or native
token even the solution?
And then you get
digging into it.
Why do you need an
append only log?
What verification and networking
cost are actually addressed?
What transactions are
actually recorded on a ledger?
I mean, these are the
basic building blocks
that if you take anything
away, hopefully it's
this one page of questions
to have some critical skills
as you go off and
somebody says, well, I've
got this great blockchain
idea or great token.
And then not to forget all the
darn challenges that we still
have-- scalability, performance,
privacy, security, network
coordination, and
interoperability.
I know only you say there's no
challenges of interoperability.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no, don't
put words in my mouth.
GARY GENSLER: So these,
I'm not going to rereview,
but they're going
to be in Canvas
if you want to grab them.
I mean, this is the same
conceptual framework for an ICO
or even in a
permissioned blockchain,
which I sense a lot of you
are thinking about doing.
So some statistics, and
then we'll close it out.
And these are just fun charts
that will all be in Canvas.
And I just went around
finding different websites.
I don't know that you can
trust any of these numbers,
but they're the best
numbers out there.
So here are some
of the industries.
23% is infrastructure.
That's $5 billion of raised,
but most of that, I think,
is the EOS.
I think that's called an
infrastructure project,
infrastructure
because EOS is trying
to compete with Ethereum.
Finance communication trading
and investment payments,
you see some consistency, a lot
of financial sector use cases.
Gaming, and then you're
down to 2% and 3% slices.
So there's just a little sense
of some of the industries.
And again, this will
all be on Canvas.
Here's published ICOs.
We peaked at about 500 a
month, 400 or 500 a month
in February through April.
We're down to about
200 a month now.
Now, this means published.
That doesn't mean they've
necessarily raised.
We're just under about 5,000
that have been published.
Maybe 3,000 give or take
have raised some money.
And only about half
of those actually
exist today, or that you can
find them somewhere and so
forth.
The market-- this is the third
quarter based on a website
called ICO Rating.
They publish a quarterly report.
I'm not saying it's
completely exhaustive.
1.8 billion ICOs raised
down 78% from Q2,
just to give you a
sense of the size.
But $1 billion of blockchain
VC raised in the same quarter.
ICOs surpassed VC
investment in blockchain
in the third quarter of '17.
Before that, VC
raise was higher.
And I think it's coming back.
And it's a reasonable shot that
in one or two more quarters,
the VC number will be
higher than the ICO number.
But this is just a hunch
as to where we're headed.
Some other statistics--
of the 600,
this is one quarter, about 200
a month or 600 for the quarter
that they tracked, 84% are
on the Ethereum and platform.
Almost every data source I can
find ranges from 80% to 85%.
So it's still highly focused
on Ethereum platform.
And I would say as the
ICO boom comes off,
it's probably also
one of the reasons
that Ethereum, the price
and valuation of Ethereum
has come off as well, just
because of the relationships.
Only 4% of these
600, or 24 of them,
got listed on an exchange,
that they raised enough money.
But look at that.
57% raised less than
$100,000 a piece.
So it's highly
concentrated in a small--
67% percent of the DApp
ICos were unsuccessful,
whatever their measurement
of unsuccessful.
They didn't raise money or they
raised a little bit of money,
but the website went dark.
That's all within three months.
And again, I can't speak to
how they measure success.
But 76% were just an idea.
This is, again,
based on ICO rating.
And 1.37%-- you were at 1%?
You were at 5%?
But 1.7% had their code.
So 3% were either fully ready
or had their source code.
So you want to read the white
paper if you're really curious.
But 76%, you might say how can
you raise money on an idea?
This is really prefunding.
And this is even after
the bloom is off the rose.
This is the third quarter 2018.
Here's the industries again
for the third quarter--
exchanges and wallets,
financial services, trading.
So it's deeply finance, a little
bit health care, and so forth.
And let's see.
I think I have one
or two more of these.
Oh, this is how they've done.
This is interesting to me.
This is the returns
in the third quarter.
Now, I know this is
actually before the sell-off
for the last week and a half.
The only sector
that went up is--
I don't even know
which ICOs these are--
the marketing and advertising.
Everything else got clobbered.
I've been around markets for
a long time, three or four
decades.
When you get this type
of return picture,
there's going to be fewer
ICOs rather than more ICOs,
because it just keeps cutting
down the investor enthusiasm.
I don't think it's FOMO anymore.
What's the opposite of FOMO?
AUDIENCE: Here.
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
So all right, so study
questions for next Tuesday
is just we're going
to go back to ICOs,
talk a little bit about
the scams and frauds.
We're going to talk about
the Securities and Exchange
Commission.
We've already talked a lot
about their design feature.
So it's going to be
like going back to some
of the regulatory things.
I'll try to look up on the
Filecoin questions as well.
We will drop one
more reading in,
which is just this
quick two-pager
from the SEC from
last Friday that
may be worthwhile looking at.
And this is the
best thing I could
do to say Happy Thanksgiving.
I know it's a Bitcoin
turkey, blockchain turkey,
and the like.
But I do think it's
an interesting thing.
ICOs are a new means
of crowdfunding.
And there's been so many
different ways to raise money
over centuries.
This is not equity, it's not
debt, it's something else.
I don't know how much of
it will last three and five
years from now, but the
idea that you could pre-fund
an idea, a deferred
revenue or some sort,
but it's not your revenue,
is an interesting evolution
in the markets of finance.
But I think if you can't assess
the viability of the use case
and figure out what
really is the benefit
of the token economics--
that comes back to, is
there really a benefit
to having a native
token on a network
for a good or a service, for
file storage, for ride sharing,
and so forth?
And then I think this will
just be looked back-- decades
from now, people look
back and say, well, that
was a small, little,
odd thing that happened
back there in the 2010s.
But it might be.
I'm not all the way to zero.
I think there might
be a reason why
folks want to have
a native currency,
a native token to
jumpstart a network
and to motivate a network
over time, whether it's
like swords and skins and
shields in a gaming site.
The majority of ICOs
have failed already.
And because they keep
failing so fast--
I don't know-- by
the end of this year
or certainly by the middle
of next year, over 90% or 95%
of them will have failed, like
if you take the whole total.
So it's pretty clear
it's going to come down.
There's going to be
less and less probably
in this ICO thing.
It doesn't mean that
blockchain technology is over.
It just means that this
wave, I think, will diminish.
So Happy Thanksgiving.
Is there a question
before we all
go to Thanksgiving and
airports and trains?
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
Does any ICO take ownership of
the company besides [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: So we'll
talk about this Tuesday.
The question is,
can you ever have
an ownership right in a token?
The answer is yes,
you could structure
it to have voting rights,
governance rights, dividend
rights.
There are a handful
that have done that.
But after the DAO
or DAO issuance,
which did give some governance
rights and cash flow rights,
the SEC spoke to that in a paper
one year ago or 15 months ago.
There's very few of them.
Most of them are what you would
call either utility tokens
or service tokens,
where you have a right
to get a service
or a good usually
from the rest of that
network, rather than back.
I'll check on Filecoin, but the
answer is yes you can do it,
but it's a rare
case that does it.
So thank you.
Happy Thanksgiving.
Thank you for all
being in this class.
[APPLAUSE]